the biden administration is buying an
additional 200 million doses of covet-19
vaccine
ahead of the potential need for booster
shots and a vaccine for children
under the age of 12 later this year the
action comes as the highly contagious
delta variant is driving up coronavirus
infections across the country
new cases are up 167 percent in the u.s
over the past two weeks this is just 49
percent of americans are fully
vaccinated
michael george is here with the latest
michael good morning dana good morning
cases right now are exploding in areas
where people aren't vaccinated
take alabama the state with the lowest
vaccination rate coveted cases have
doubled there in a week
and republican governor kay ivey made a
strong plea to people refusing to get
the vaccine
you know we've got to get folks to take
the shot
the vaccine is the greatest weapon we
have to fight kobe there's no question
about that
only 39 percent of alabamans are
vaccinated
60 percent are not what is it going to
take to get people to get shots in ours
i don't know you tell me
folks supposed to have common sense
but it's time to start blaming the
unvaccinated folks not the regular folks
it's the unvaccinated folks that are
letting us stay less than
half of the population in 16 states have
received at least one dose of a coveted
vaccine
bringing more patients to hospitals in
need of critical care
none of us believe that we would be in
the situation that we were in now
if we would have more of our population
vaccinated dr frank cormier
is medical director at our lady of
lourdes hospital in louisiana
it's a top coveted hot spot state along
with nevada
florida arkansas and missouri we're
starting to
experience enough patients where it
concerns us once again
that that we're utilizing a major part
of our resources are being shifted to
being able to help and accommodate the
influx of patients
a concern echoed in san antonio where
chief charles hood
runs emergency services our citizens are
still going to be in accidents
they're still going to be injured
they're still going to have heart
attacks
that causes us to potentially divert to
other locations
and maybe they don't get the standard of
care as quick as they could
so once again doctors nurses and first
responders are being stretched to the
limits in some parts of the country
and it's been frustrating for some
because most of the serious cases
they're treating
could have been easily prevented if the
patients had been vaccinated
jeff michael thank you very much as you
know